hi my name is Alex I came from Russia to
Germany and today I want to invite you
to make a permanent with me around DNA
and our first stop will be at the
observation platform of Vienna Tower
oh my god whoa oh oh but I'm gonna do
that just look down I'm on the seventh
heaven I'm really happy
adrenaline very high oh it's like an on
a postcard
I would stay here forever just take a
look at this
the guy climbing up this bro
excuse me sir excuse me justic English
hello I can't believe it he's not real
oh wow this is the city wall Wow this is
the history Oh terrific
that's nice everything here was to
protect the city and now it's just
landmark this picture shows how people
worked at a factory those times and also
they have the happier names of of the
actual workers
pretty effect it's like I'm touching it
now but I can fill anything with my
fingers but I'm touching it now they use
trash to make this hoof somebody takes
care of this Monument I think
Wow it's beautiful inside oh and the
organ wow it's huge
Oh terrific this church was almost them
almost completely damaged in 1945 but
then it was restored and now you can see
how beautiful it is and I really like
this that's amazing I'm in charge in
Germany and that's that's what I didn't
think about a year ago for example it
means that life is forever literally
unpredictable and I'm very glad that I'm
here
it's really hard but I have to do that I
want to go up to the mother where am i
oh I can see something Wow oh yeah oh
the whole city in front of me
today I I've visited a lot of places
here in Vienna and now I know a lot of
information about the city and it's time
to say goodbye and I hope to see you
soon here in Vienna bye bye